in this video I'll be challenging people
to make 100K in a year or we kill them
just kidding the average US salary is
$59,000 a year college degrees are only
going up and people are on average
spending 7 hours a day on their phones
so if you had a gun to your head and one
year to make $100,000 or you die what
would you do that's where we're here in
New York City to find out you guys want
to answer a quick question for a video
if you had to make $100,000 in the next
year gun to your head I'm going to pull
the trigger if you don't give me 100
Grand what would you do what would you
do what would you do what would you do
honestly I I don't know I'd probably die
like what would I do to make that money
yeah I'm going have to rob a bang bro I
don't know what to tell I would probably
say something inappropriate only fans
you only fans for $100,000 [__] yeah
only fans you do only fans I don't know
like sell feet piics something easy like
that I don't know sell feetpics sell my
ex's bike I'd steal it and sell it
probably what would your family think if
you did only fans
um I would try my hardest for them to
not find out about that but they would
not be very happy I would go around
trying to get people to invest in my
business so boom if they give me this
exact amount for
$5.99 I will quadruple so I'll be
finessing everybody get my hyk and then
I give it back at the end do you see
Wall Street right they're all finessers
I I don't know get a job get a job yeah
probably would you wait until the end to
rob the bank would you try something
else I probably I would probably wait
till the last minute to rob the bank
that will minimize the time delivery of
the money cuz I'm assuming I'm giving
you the money I would probably divide my
time between passive income real estate
and crypto I think those are the top
earners at this month you follow at
wealth on Instagram and you did the that
was actually my source try and sell cars
sell cars sell some real expensive cars
steal cars and then sell them steal the
cars then sell you said it not me what
would you do
ooh I'm going to kill you B I'm going to
kill you
major are you get in this are you
getting this [__] bro what the [__] all
right well now you have some time to
think about the answer yeah I do we
should go interview wait wait yeah I
feel like you guys have someone more
interesting over
there why would anyone beat his
ass La I'm kind of obsessed with her
actually yeah she'll ask her on a date
oh no not like that no you don't swing
that way no what would you do I'd take
out a loan take out a loan yeah and be
in like crippling debt and then figure
it out later if you had to make $100,000
this year or you die what do you do a
smart way if if you have good credit
just get a loan of 100K oh that's yeah
he's smart that's right there that's
easy how much do you think you could get
out with your credit I might have to use
someone else's so You' pull some strings
use someone else else's credit yeah ask
people on the street for money so you'd
become homeless basically you think
you'll make $300 a day doing that if I
really like put myself into it yeah okay
so beg on the street haven't heard that
one yet how much do you think homeless
people make in a year maybe like a
thousand I don't know so then why would
you do that to make $100,000 well plus
that and a job so in you're off time you
don't go home you just like lay in the
street with a bucket sales sales what
would you sell I'll pretty much sell it
off so you just become like a high
ticket closer pretty much okay what
about you make my own clothing brand why
don't you do it now I am in the process
of it so you're going to make 100K in
the next year off of that though I'm
manifesting it yeah how are you going to
Market it lots of different ways Tik Tok
is definitely one of them social media
just in general social media is powerful
that's the way right now with Drop
Shipping you start Drop Shipping and
like promote your products on like Tik
Tok and stuff Tik Tok like all social
platforms basically what about you I'll
buy a property rent it out I'll be
having like crazy side hustles I will
rent my apartment and just be homeless
and then try to find some no I I have a
lot of friends so they'll let you crash
in like the bathtub or something yeah
taking a risk I'm wter right in this
[__] you know a couple packs yeah [__]
more than a couple a candy of
candy pack I know what do you do like
you just die sell drugs sell drugs a lot
of girls said only fans so like I think
the guy's option is just selling drugs I
guess so put that drama degree to work
do you think that drama degree will be
making you good money or do you do it
more for passion I feel like if I said
no to that I would kind of just be like
talking down to myself a bit I'd go into
firewall protection like um online
protection I'd go into that industry cuz
there's a lot of Bank in that you go
into it now it's too time consuming for
the personal stuff I want to do so I
want to Chase my own stuff um I would
probably lose my virginity and just um
sell some she sheenus sell your
virginity yeah I was sling sheenus will
the sheets bleed maybe maybe damn you to
make 100 Grand so are you going to sell
your virginity multiple times at least
5,000 a pop you know what so you'll sell
your virginity 20 times yeah I would
actually do hair cuz I'm really good at
it oh you already make 100,000 a year
basically okay yeah and you're good
start a clothing brand [__] it start a
clothing brand that's your ticket you
can do to make 100K easyier than you can
just rob a bank rob a bank get 100K and
you don't die oh they're in class right
now it's pretty good it's pretty good
content it's pretty good uh good
lecture on the path you're going right
now what do you think your net worth
will be in 10 years where do you think
you'll be financially in 10 years
500,000 um I'd be lucky if it's in like
10,000
70k with the moves I'm making now be
honest not as much as I wanted to be but
where I wanted to be I would say upper
Millions I hope I can get the million
something like that 10,000 a year do you
think you'll be an above average earner
to be honest since I'm a drama major
I'll probably be a little bit broke what
about you that's hard man I want to say
like 100 million yeah 100 million yeah
are you going to be Kim she's not Kim
she's him just comfortable enough to pay
rent somewhere and eat where do you see
yourself financially in 10 years like
what will your net worth be I'm not too
worried about my finances but I feel
like I could float my own boat if that
makes sense sugar daddy in 10 years oh
[__] no if a rich husband comes my way
I'm not going to say is that the ideal a
rich husband a rich husband that treats
me well yeah okay what about you rich
husband n i mean in 10 years you said
yeah I want to be a millionaire by then
how do you promote your brand I post on
on Instagram mostly but I'm just now
creating more content content for you
got you got to pump out content bro
that's the future I think I'll be very
comfortable I'd be able to sustain aive
for myself do whatever I want travel you
want a rich husband or be a boss [__]
both both yeah in 10 years I'm not going
to lie like I'm definitely going to be
retired I'm definitely going to be like
traveling the world [__] hella girls
n lie let me let me slow down I'mma to
have one girlfriend and I'm going to
have mad side hoes like
what my own business is chilling uh
people working for me me yeah that's the
that's the that's the vibe like I want
to do that I don't want to be working
unless they really really need me or
it's a big event or a big client passive
income is the way to go if you can make
passive income we just looked over and
saw an LGB church so how the [__] this
happened if you use a side door the side
door yeah is on that side or that side
awesome thank you thank you I've never
seen a pride flag on the side of a
church the senior minister is gay
actually the senior minister at this
church is gay yeah yeah I don't think
I've ever heard of that it's not a gay
church it's for everybody it's for gays
and straight people totally in 10 years
is it going to be easier to make this
kind of money or not yes I know AI is
what scares me the most AI could do a
lot of jobs just easy programming is
cheaper for them to make money waste
money on AI then so basically now is the
time to get rich now is the time bullet
and here you are eating pizza jerking
off I'm make love we don't we don't do
that no more I heard it lows your
testosterone gym grind that's beautiful
that's beautiful if people use the
future to their advantage if people use
technology to their advantage social
media and stuff then it's going to be
for the better like the future is going
to be a lot
brighter bro seeing that [__] just makes
me want to end it all [__] being an
[Music]
influencer do you think that who the
president is determines how hard it is
to make the $100,000 to an extent it
doesn't all boil down to one person it's
more so on you as the person on you and
also what the entire government is doing
is important it's yeah like if the
country shut down with Co or is it open
what do you mean no never mind never
mind you want to be independent or do
you want a man a man a man to pay a man
to pay both I guess both yeah I got a
man I'm independent would you rather
stay home with the kids no never no no
what about you no no not an option not
even an option no okay so your plan to
escape the matrix is to die be homeless
you're going to be a high ticket closer
and you're going to sell clothing let me
ask you what would you do I'll post
videos on Tik Tok it's pretty easy to
scale to like 10K a month doing that all
right man I don't know you just met you
know you for the last 4 minutes but I
wish you nothing but the best you you
too guys you guys are great thank you if
you want to learn too you can click the
free training in the bio so to escape
the matrix you're going to scam people
on a 4X steal cars and sell them he said
it not me a lot of you guys have
probably seen me talking about the
creativity program and all that [__] so
if you're are interested in more
information I made a free video for you
guys explaining it all down below so you
can go check that out right after the
video hit the fan cuz I didn't take
action when I had the chance going to
All Fall Down